THE DOJ AND THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT ARE WORKING WITH THE
BEING COMMISSION AND SEVEN
OTHER COUNTRIES TO GO AFTER ONE
OF PUTIN'S BIGGEST SUPPORTS AND
THAT'S THE OLIGARCHS.
CNN'S DREW GRIFFIN REPORTS.
>> ON THE SHORE OF THE BLACK
SEA, IT CAN ONLY BE DESCRIBED
AS A PALACE.
190,000 SQUARE FEET.
FROM THE AIR, YOU CAN SEE THE
CHURCH, TEA HOUSE AND
AMPHITHEATER.
AND REPORTEDLY, AN UNDERGROUND
HOCKEY RINK.
WITH A NO-FLY ZONE AND A NO
BOAT ZONE.
THIS, ACCORDING TO AN
INVESTIGATION LAST YEAR BY THE
JAILED RUSSIAN OPPOSITION
LEADER ALEXEI NAVALNY'S GROUP.
THEY CLAIM THIS GILDED PALACE,
FIT FOR KING, WAS BUILT FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THIS PALACE IS VERY MUCH A
SYMBOL OF PUTIN'S RUSSIA.
HE NO LONGER SEES HIMSELF AS A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE, AS AN
ELECTED FIGURE.
HE SEES HIMSELF AS A CZAR, A
KING OF SORTS.
AND A RUSSIAN CZAR, OF COURSE,
DESERVES A PALACE.
>> CNN CAN'T INDEPENDENTLY
VERIFY PUTIN'S CONNECTION TO
THE PALACE.
AND PUTIN'S SPOKESMAN DENIES
THAT PUTIN OWNS IT OR ANY
CONNECTION.
BUT SOURCES AND DOCUMENTS FROM
THE GROUP ALL POINT TO HOW
OLIGARCHS CORRUPTLY ENRICH
RUSSIA'S PRESIDENT.
>> --
PAID BY RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS, BY
RUSSIAN STATE OWNED COMPANIES,
MONEY FROM REGULAR PEOPLE,
STOLEN AND DIVERTED INTO
BUILDING THIS HORRENDOUS THING
ON THE BLACK SEA.
>> ACCORDING TO THE
INVESTIGATION AND A
WHISTLEBLOWER WHO CAME FORWARD,
THE MONEY FOR THE PALACE CAME
FROM A RUSSIAN INVESTMENT FUND
COMPANY THAT SOLICITED CHARITY
DONATIONS FROM THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS.
>> THERE ARE THESE RUMORS ABOUT
PUTIN BEING THE RICHEST MAN IN
THE WORLD'S.
AND HE MAY BE.
IT'S VERY, VERY HARD TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HIS WEALTH IS.
>> RUMORED TO BE WORTH MORE
THAN 100 BILLION DOLLARS
OFFICIALLY, PUTIN CLAIMED A
MODEST SALARY IN 2020, VALUED
AT ABOUT $140,000.
BUT HIS OFFICIAL INCOME IS
IRRELEVANT.
RUSSIA WATCHERS SAY THAT PUTIN
CONTROLS RUSSIA BY DETERMINING
WHO GETS MONEY AND WHO DOES NOT,
WHO GETS TO RUN BUSINESSES,
SKIMS PROFIT AND HOW THE WEALTH
IS PASSED ON.
HE DOES NOT NEED ANY ASSETS
LISTED IN HIS NAME, SAYS
JOURNALIST TOM MERGE US.
IT'S ALL HIS WHEN HE ASKS.
>> --
ULTIMATELY, THEY OWE EVERYTHING
THEY HAVE TO THE BOSS.
WITH A CLICK AT THE FINGERS.
AND AS HE SHOWN IN THE PAST,
PUTIN CAN TAKE EVERYTHING FROM
AN OLIGARCHY, NO MATTER HOW
RICH.
THEY ARE ULTIMATELY DEPENDENT
ON HIM.
>> BY THE SYSTEM, INTERFERE IN
POLITICS AND FACE HIS WRATH.
EXILED RUSSIAN OLIGARCH --
CONVICTED OF TAX EVASION AND
FRAUD, SPENT TEN YEARS IN A
RUSSIAN PRISON, HE SAYS, FOR
NOT PLAYING PUTIN'S GAME.
HE CLAIMS PUTIN IS PARANOID,
DANGEROUS AND MUST BE STOPPED.
>> [INTERPRETER]
ALL THE ACCOUNTS OF ALL THE
OLIGARCHS WHO FUNCTION AS
PUTIN'S WALLET MUST STOP AND
THEY MUST ALL FEEL THE PAIN
RIGHT NOW.
IT MUST CONTINUE UNTIL THE WAR
ENDS.
>> NEWLY-IMPOSED SANCTIONS HAVE
NOW MADE IT HARD FOR MANY OF
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRES TO DO
BUSINESS OUTSIDE OF RUSSIA.
YACHTS, BANK ACCOUNTS FROZEN.
INSIDE, THE RUSSIAN ECONOMY
SHOWS SIGNS OF CRUMBLING.
BUT CHIPPING AWAY AT THE BRUTAL
HOLD ON POWER WILL TAKE TIME.
AND FROM HIS ACTIONS, OBSERVERS
BELIEVE THAT PUTIN'S STRATEGY
IS FAR BEYOND PERSONAL RICHES.
>> HE WANTS TO REBUILD RUSSIA
AS A GREAT POWER.
YOU ALMOST HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE CZARIST DAYS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT.
>> JUST LOOK AGAIN AT THE
PURPORTED PALACE, AND SIMILAR
TO THE GOLDEN EAGLE A TOP OF
THE WINTER PALACE THAT BELONG
TO THE LAST CZAR.
GETTING TO PUTIN OR IS
OLIGARCHY MAYBE IMPOSSIBLE,
EVEN THREE SEIZURES OF
SANCTIONS.
THEY HAVE GONE TO GREAT LENGTHS
TO HIDE THEIR ASSETS BEHIND
MULTIPLE SHELL COMPANIES,
SAFELY IN WESTERN COUNTRIES
LIKE THE UNITED STATES, ONE
EXPERT TELLING CNN THAT THERE
IS LITERALLY NO PAPER TRAIL.
>> DON?
>> ALL RIGHT, DREW GRIFFIN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GOING TO BRING IN CNN'S
GLOBAL AFFAIRS ANALYST, SUSAN
GILLESPIE.
WOW, STUNNING, THIS LEVEL OF
WEALTH IS REALLY STAGGERING
HERE.
HAS PUTI
THIS LEVELN MADE HIMSELF AZAR?
>> THAT ALWAYS WAS THE
FRAMEWORK IMPROBABLY ENOUGH FOR
THIS FORMER KGB LIEUTENANT
COLONEL, WHO IS HANGING A
PORTRAIT OF PETER THE GREAT, IN
HIS MODEST OFFICE.
THIS SORT OF POSTWAR LENINGRAD,
WITH CRUMBLING PALACES OF THE
CZARS AROUND HIM.
NOW YOU SEE THE ENORMOUS --
THE INVESTIGATION SAYING THAT
THE NEW REPORT, IT'S REALLY AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEVEL OF DETAIL
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO TURN UP,
JUST ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR OVER
THE TOP --
GOTCHA IS A CRAZY WORD FOR
SOMETHING SO BIG.
THING SO BIG AND
ALL OF THESE GOVERNMENTS ARE
NOW GOING AFTER OLIGARCH WEALTH,
SUSAN.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING, DO YOU
THINK THAT THEY CAN KEEP THIS
UP?
DO YOU THINK THAT IT IS GOING
TO PUT PRESSURE ON PUTIN?
IF HE IS THE ONE WHO HAS DOLED
OUT THE RICHES IN THE FIRST
PLACE, HOW EFFECTIVE COULD THIS
STRATEGY BE?
>> WELL, LOOK, THAT'S THE
QUESTION, WHAT IS THE GOAL?
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS THE
QUESTION OF WHO, IF ANYONE IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN LISTENING TO
ANYMORE?
CERTAINLY, THIS IS THE SYSTEM
THAT ENABLED HIM AT THE
BEGINNING OF HIS TENURE.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE
EFFECTIVE TO CRACK DOWN ON THE
OLIGARCHS, BUT NOW WE'RE TWO
DECADES IN, AND WE SEE THE
PHYSICAL SIGNS OF ISOLATION.
PUTIN, AT THE END OF HIS LONG
TABLE, SO IF YOU LISTEN TO
OLIGARCHS, HE PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN IN THIS WAR IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SO THAT'S ONE QUESTION THAT ONE
HAS, BUT THE FLIPSIDE IS
CAUSING HIM POTENTIALLY TO LOSE
SUPPORT, ENORMOUSLY, FROM THESE
WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO ARE USED TO
OPERATING WITH IMPUNITY IN THE
WEST.
GOING TO THEIR APARTMENTS IN
LONDON, AND SENDING THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL IN THE UNITED STATES
AND EUROPE, THAT'S CUT OFF TO
THEM NOW, AND THE QUESTION IS
WHAT KIND OF BACKLASH DOES THAT
GENERATE ON PUTIN?
>> PUTIN AND HIS OLIGARCHS,
SUSAN, HAVE HAD DECADES TO HIDE
AND WHERE THEIR MONEY.
CAN SANCTIONS INFLICT REAL PAIN
ON PUTIN AND HIS CRONIES?
>> NOT AT THE PERSONAL LEVEL.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO, AS YOU
SEEN, ARE LITERALLY GROTESQUELY
RICH.
YOU SEE THESE IN SOME OF THESE
SUPER YACHTS THAT ARE BEING
IMPOUNDED BY THE ITALIANS IN
THE LIKE.
ABSOLUTELY LEVELS OF THIEVERY
AND CORRUPTION THAT ARE
GROTESQUE.
SO, IT'S NOT GOING TO AFFECT
THEM PERSONALLY IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY LIVE THEIR LIVES, EXCEPT
THAT THEY CAN NO LONGER GO TO
EUROPE.
DUBAI IS STILL OPEN TO THEM.
LOOK AT THE PROPERTY THAT THEY
HAVE THEIR, AND YOU SEE PRIVATE
JETS STILL GOING THERE TODAY,
WHILE MUCH OF THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS CLOSED OFF TO THOSE
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS WEALTH.
I THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
FACTOR IN UNDERSTANDING THE
NATURE OF THE GOVERNMENT, THAT
PUTIN HAS PUT TOGETHER, THE
SYSTEM IN WHICH A SMALL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE BASICALLY LOOTED THE
COUNTRY FOR THEIR OWN PURPOSES.
>> THESE OLIGARCHS OWE
EVERYTHING TO PUTIN.
SO IS IT THEM OR THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE WHO WILL NEED TO DECIDE
IF PUTIN HAS GONE TOO FAR.
>> WELL, AGAIN, YOU LOOK AT THE
NATURE OF THE REGIME THAT PUTIN
HAS, ONE THING IS THAT OVER
TIME, HE'S HAD MORE THAN TWO
DECADES IN POWER HE HAS BECOME
PROGRESSIVELY MORE ISOLATED AND
SURROUNDED, REALLY BY THE
REMNANTS OF THE SECURITY
SERVICES, THAT HE SURROUNDED
HIMSELF WITH.
THESE ARE NOT THE BIG BUSINESS
PEOPLE, THOUGH MANY OF THEM
HAVE BENEFITED FROM CORRUPTION
AND GAINED LARGE PERSONAL
WEALTH AS WELL.
SO, THE QUESTION IS, IS THIS
SYSTEM OF ONE MAN AUTHORITARIAN
RULE, IT HAS REALLY GONE IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
RATHER THAN OLIGARCHS HAVING TO
SAY OVER VLADIMIR PUTIN, HE
SEEMS TO PUT MORE AND MORE
POWER ONTO HIMSELF PERSONALLY.
HIS SPEECH THAT HE GAVE
YESTERDAY, DON, IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY CHILLING.
I REALLY WOULD RECOMMEND ANYONE
TO LOOK THROUGH A TRANSLATION
OF THAT, IT'S ALMOST
STALINESQUE IN ITS PROMISE OF A
NEW PURGE INSIDE OF RUSSIA, TO
ACCOMPANY THE HORRIFIC MILITARY
ACTION OF UKRAINE NEXT DOOR.
IT'S REALLY SUGGESTI